welcome back everyone this is your thor  eleven thunder trailer order number one  because there's probably gonna be a  bunch of changes i'm dealing with very  little here so uh please understand that  there's going to be some changes along  the way subscribe though because i am  going to be updating this and giving you  guys uh hopefully the entire movie i was  about 85 percent successful with my  doctor strange the multiverse advantage  trailer order so you know that i i work  hard for you guys to give you the most  accurate uh again enjoy and i'll see you  guys at the end of the video  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you